tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video
sono fa vj oggi siamo sul gioco che non
ho intanto è fermo c'è la pausa se non
sono anche partiti è già in pausa
perfetto ecco già sono stati trovati nei
primi 5 6 con un record di 20 ragazzi
siamo sul gioco una serie che non ho mai
fatto proprio c'è la prima volta che
faccio un gioco del genere però il face
quest ragazzi che è uscito il 6 è uscita
hanno fatto anche il 6 dic io non so
come sia possibile è uscito da
pochissimo è questo sudore in hd lo
rende unico comunque ragazzi a parte
tutto questo milioni che si tratta
almeno già il fatto che il nuovo che è
successo
c'era un cristiano che stava mangiando
la pizza poi entrato david beckham con
degli spaghetti al posto dei capelli e
gli ha rubato la pizza perfetto e l'ha
preso a calci e se non calciatore che
cosa poteva fare sarebbe questa la trama
è questa la trama è come vivete le i
giochi seri con la trama proprio corposa
minchia come final fantasy uguale enti
livelli come al solito dai partiamo dal
primo come che che va più veloce
perfetto devo farlo andare più veloce
forse no ma non sono ci sono 10 di cazzo
fossero 20 all'ora ma che non possono
anche vedere livelli che ci sono mi fa
ripartire da zero to che c'è le
sopracciglia belle mi spieghi cosa
dovrei fare
qui perché dovresti metterti a fare sta
cosa vicino ad una fine ho già capito ho
già [ __ ] lo sapevo lo sapevo
terminati non ho capito guardando la
finestra che dovevo falsa cosa c'è
vabbè meraviglioso livello completa
bravi bravi avete fatto un gioco della
madonna stavolta credete che la
soddisfazione nel corpo quando vengono
secolo fantastico siete uguali cazzo
siete voi uguale è più la differenza che
c'è tra me e brock lesnar da tosto spero
mi sta sorridendo in una maniera
incredibile bellissima beh a parte sta
roba devo cosa faccio a questo che non è
esattamente skrillex però vabbè me lo
faccio andar bene uguale dei bimbi dei
bicipiti 7
scott addio se veramente figo ma spiega
miste allora cosa devo fare
attiva ma ho vinto ho vinto
era questo perché chi è che senso
inutile che hanno sinora lascia il vuoto
dentro proprio cos'è sta roba da
prendere
ascolta zio hai voglia di giocare ha
scosso ti facciamo giocare in due che
divertente ho perso ed è guarda non
avevo dubbi
siccome sono un giocatore esperto di
troll face quest noto che c'è qualcosa
di strano nel personaggio quindi devo
cambiare ma sei serie veramente se non
giocare a squash con la mia testa
david beckham è che ho trovato di nuovo
andiamo avanti che voglio ancora capire
che cos'è bellissimo era più bello ha
solo dei teletubbies comunque che questa
nuova dalla 20 un sottomarino porca
[ __ ] non era così fico come pensavano
ascolta zio atti giri ed è un credo ti
vogliano ecco per un ventilatore anno
sulle eliche bene ho vinto ho vinto
l'inflazione finisce così sto giocando
le ferite perché mi piace troppo gola
l'essenza pura del videogame la
meraviglia ma scusatemi ma perché sto
tizio si deve mettere a far paesistica
che ci allo stesso fisico di di bello
spiega mi zio qual è il tuo broncos atti
affligge il cuore vabbè amico mio giuro
diventerai schwarznegger tra pochissimo
credimi comunque ascoltami c'era mister
spaghetti in agguato per chi l'ha visto
allora posso tirarmi su adesso adesso
che sono col cane a ok sono fatta se
preferisco spalare merda una cosa
indecente provavi andiamo avanti
se avete dei tic specialmente tu non so
qual è il vostro problema ma vi
compatisco ecco io ne ho di peggiori di
problemi molto peggiori cosa faccio non
prendermi al volo al volo no cosa da
fare mi prendi questo che c'hai le mani
alzate mettiti davanti mi prendi al volo
fare un attimo dopo devo devo cliccare
la tizia lati siamo anche un occhio però
non so se va bene però va bene
all'opposto musicato sulla gente
perfetta l'avevo detto riprendeva che
l'ho fatta ragazzi siamo a livello 7 o
così finito tra l'altro sono indotto
pochissimo
io sono un maestro della pesistica
red i migliori tecniche che ieri iuri
chechi
sì adesso con uno ce l'ha dovrei fare
credo
ecco vedi la scimmia mi riesce bene solo
la scimmia volo se la scimmia che rompe
io devo rompere vetri sto gioco cioè
fatto apposta ruolo l'onyx è ovvio
devo sto inglobando una palla bene
sempre di bene in meglio ragazzi sto
gioco è meraviglioso bisogna fare qui
spengo la tv non cambio canale comunque
a parte sta roba devo che mi al canale
l'abbiamo faccio forse così ragazzi
cambio canale magari ogni tanto c'è
anche una pizza una birra vedi come
viene il fisico cioè stata grande 0 hai
vinto tutto dalla vita tom a dirlo prima
facciamoci troppe domande che poi non
troviamo risposte andiamo avanti così
mele singolo tutte mascot passi ma
sgoliamo cioè tutto quello che fa non
sono anche un po ubriaco perché io lo
reggo l'alcol ragazzi lo reggo da morire
guarda qua che ti guarda qua sono un
freno prima non ci sarei mai riuscito
adesso se con aspettati ma chissà se
cosa succedeva se per curiosità proprio
lì prende voto è mica sei un fenomeno
ragazzi credo sia credo sia l'ultimo
credo non lo so ciao zio tu che ci hai
bicipiti grossi come la minchia mia
famiglia vedere cosa sai fare tirargli
un pugnetto bravo ma per me va bene lo
fa ragazzi no fermi allo sposto proprio
perfetto grande non avrei bisogno guarda
game complete ed 137 clicks perfetto
ragazzi l'ho scaricato anche su questo
sul telefono perché
cer porca [ __ ] io posso disegnare i
beni si vede che cosa sta disegnando sul
telefono è bellissimo
ciao mi puzza è poi sempre tutto ho
vinto scritto ciò un impulso allo stile
ciò mi buzzolan au prov into one ragazzi
appena scoperto che l'avevo già fatto
quindi [ __ ] faccio qualcos'altro a
caso premo questo me ne frega niente le
previsioni di paolo fox io sono ariete
pin corrono tutti l'ho scaricata
stamattina questa è [ __ ] cliente ecco
porca [ __ ] tragicamente devo
attaccare questi cosi prima c'è da
attaccarli senza beccare le altre
palline bellissima è abbastanza semplice
krakow è una merda una merda di merda se
non si fosse porca [ __ ] dai non possa
essere così disastroso non ha ancora
giocato no alla sentire jean giono già
era accorto tra facebook per l'amor di
dio almeno non le figure di merda grazie
gradiente tua madre è buttata alla
scalata elimina i virus t che elimino la
famiglia per qualsiasi gioco io faccia
posso disegnare dei peni spiegate ma
comunque ragazzi già posso fare non è
che non sono così impedito sono sono
così impedito dietro alle marche dove
vuoi trovare le marche zio stanno sopra
l'umbria [ __ ]
direi che dopo sto squallore di battuta
possa effettivamente ritirarmi in modo
definitivo per ragazzi che ho concluso
qui vi do spero che vi sia piaciuto è
stato un po disadattato di giada
disagiato tutto insieme ai trofei square
poi è finito troppo in fretta non ho
fatto questo la scelta più saggia della
mia vita e quindi ragazzi spero che ai
video vi sia piaciuto a cose in seguito
è piaciuta stato momento mi piace anche
a pace di facebook e cavani video tra
transizione senza velo rialzo